hey there in this video we're going to
build a command line Chasse application
my name is Alex and I normally run a
YouTube channel called code cast you can
find a link around here somewhere the
other day my friend Hugo and I we built
a little command-line chat application
and wrote about it over a medium and I
thought it would be a really pleasant
casual project to teach you how to build
step-by-step hair on the free code camp
YouTube channel in terms of
prerequisites for what you need to know
already it would be good if you had some
basic JavaScript and nodejs knowledge
already but you might benefit from
seeing some things you haven't learned
yet so I'll leave that up to you a big
component of our app will be a tool that
I'm helping to build over here at pusher
called chat heads check it in a nutshell
it's a hosted API that makes it easier
to build chat functionality into our
applications functionality like
real-time messaging typing indicators
read indicators which in turn we can use
the power and read message counts and
read receives that kind of thing you
might get the idea and if you don't it's
okay one of the best ways to learn is by
doing so in that notes let's jump in and
create a chat accounts to do that head
over to pusher comm /jacket and hit sign
up I already have an account so I'll
click sign-in instead and log in to my
existing account from here we can create
a new jacket instance by clicking on
crate new I'm going to call mine command
line charts and for now that's all we're
going to do in the dashboard we'll be
coming back here in a second to make
some up days but the time being I'm
gonna switch back to the terminal and
make a new directory called command line
chart tutorial and run NPM in it that's
why to initialize my packaged or JSON
file the first thing we'll want to do
for this project is create a chat Care
authentication server which sounds
complicated and it really isn't
in fact there's something that's so
common when you use chat cave I've
created a little snippet here that we
can copy and paste to kickstart this
project so head over to the
description to find this link copy and
paste it real quick and a new file
called server J ass we can paste there
at the top here you can see we import
some third-party and PM modules which
we'll need to install so let's quickly
install Express the Express body parts
middleware which allows our server to
pass request bodies to get that data the
cause Express middle web which can
enable cross-origin resource sharing and
of course we'll need the pusher chikan
server node or client SDK as well
speaking of which if we scroll a little
bit below the imports you can see that
we instantiate the chat case server SDK
and as we do so we pass down an instance
locator and a secret key both of which
you can access from the chat kit
dashboard so head over there and under
the keys tab copy your unique instance
locator and paste it in place of the
placeholder you'll also want to grab the
secret key and replace the placeholder
with that as well I won't explain this
violence too much death but we basically
set up that middleware we installed and
then creates a routes called slash users
which in a nutshell accepts a username
and then creates a check a user with
that username if a user with that
username does not already exist if a
user with that username already exists
it basically does nothing it just
returns a successful response to the
clients in a real world application
obviously two users with the same ID or
username can't exist at the same time
and so the logic would likely be
different but for our fairly simple
application this is good enough
similarly down here we creates an
authenticate endpoint which is a little
bit contrived as well the authenticate
endpoint is your opportunity to validate
that a user is who they say they are
however in this particular case we're
not really going to offense EK users
we're not going to ask them for a
password or anything like that so this
function is Valley
like I say contrived it simply returns a
token no matter what and that's okay for
the purposes
of this application and the very bottom
we obviously set up the server as well
make sure it's running and that's pretty
much it for the server application we
could run it now but there wouldn't be
much to see we'll come back and run it
later when it's more useful next let's
create a new file called client ojs and
in here i'm going to start by creating a
new function called main and this is
going to be an async function that we
pretty much call immediately and the
reason why we do this is so that we can
use the await keyword within the main
function if you're not too comfortable
with the async and awake keywords then I
highly recommend this talk by West bars
over here on the free code camp YouTube
channel now the first thing we'll want
to do when the user runs our application
is ask them for their username will
subsequently use this user names you
create a user via V server we just
created now to ask the user for their
user name I'm going to use an NPM module
called prompt now the way prompt works
simply is that you install it and import
it just like you would most NPM modules
you call a function called start to
initialize the module and the most
interaction happens by this gap function
to which you firstly passed some options
we'll explore this in more detail in a
second as well as typically a callback
function which is called when the user
successfully or erroneously enters an
inputs we might tweak this a little
bit's use promises but let's start off
of the basics by installing prompt so if
I head over to the terminal and quickly
run NPM install - - save prompt
and then just like we saw in the MPM
dogs we can write prompt or start and
whereas we would normally call prompt
dog GATS what I'm going to do is import
an ever module called you tell I'm going
to create a new function called gat I'm
going to set it equal to you tell the
promise if I prompt dog GATS now instead
of calling prompt dog gat which takes a
callback function we're going to call
get this local variable instead which is
equal to a function that returns a
promise now which is going to enable us
to use get with the awake keyword like
this like I skimmed over earlier the gap
function takes an options argument
really misses a schema which is quite an
overloaded term in programming but
basically is an outline of what we
expect from the user this will be the
username schema the description is
basically what you want to present to
the users will say answer your user name
and then we specify the name by which we
want to reference the user's input later
so I'll write user name then it's really
just the case of creating a result
variable and awaiting the results of
Gatz user name schema on this result we
can access the user name which is
basically the name that we supplied
above right in fact we can do this in
one step just by using object
restructuring like this and just to make
sure everything is working nice and fine
let's log out there using them to the
console as you can see when we run the
clients it asks us for our username I
write Booker and Booker is written to
the console one thing I don't really
like is this like prompt tax at the
beginning of my description the way to
disable that really simply is to set
from the message I think equal to an
empty string yeah now you can see when
we run that we don't have that black
prompt text nevermind this error I just
killed the application in fact yes come
to think of it we should probably wrap
most of this function inside of a try
catch block if an error happens we'll
right into the console
on call process that acts a with the
status code one this will just make
things a little bit easier to debug if
things go wrong this is also a good time
to mention but you might notice at times
that when I write my code is kind of
indented over the place or maybe it's
not as optimal as it could be for
example I have superfluous parentheses
or something like that yet when I save
my file everything gets nice and tidy
that's thanks to a JavaScript tool
called prettier which I have integrated
in my editor supercool tool check out if
you haven't heard it there already but
yeah now we have this username down here
we're going to want to send it to the
server
where we can create HR user and to do
that I'm going to use a third-party
model module called Axios so let's bring
an axe yours real quick and they'll
create a separate function called create
user that takes a username it's going to
be an async function and we're going to
send a post request using Axios to http
local host port 3001 I think I'll double
check in a second slash users and then
we'll specify the body to be equal to
the username and again we should
probably wrap this in a try-catch blog
just in case something goes wrong
let me quickly check severed is for the
port number as you can see it's three
thousand to one perfect so but down here
instead of printing the user to the
console we can write create user and
we'll actually to a wipeout resort right
there
let's test this out real quick so let me
create another splits here I'll render
server remember I said it wasn't really
useful to run before but now it is if I
run the application and I answer the
username Booker we should see in the
server out / and we do a user called
Booker was created if I run the clients
again and I try and essentially login as
Booker again now the user already exists
we see that written service server as
well prequel right
you know alice is pretty cool connecting
to chat case while I'm here I'm going to
install the pusher check a client's SDK
the reason why I say it so slowly is
because it's important to realize that
earlier we installed the server chatty
SDK and now we're installing the clients
Chuck SDK often these would happen in
different projects but because we're
kind of condensing them it might seem a
bit confusing at the top here we can
import jacket in fact specifically we're
going to want to bring in the chat chat
manager and the Chuck it's hoping
provider and then down here just beneath
the call to create user I'm going to
initialize jacket or more specifically
the chat chat manager I have a handy
little snippet for this because I do it
quite often the first thing you need to
do when initializing the chat manager is
specify your instance locator now this
is the same instance locator we copied
earlier from the dashboard so let's copy
again or copy it from your server file
it's the exact same the user ID in our
case is going to be equal to the user's
username this can be a string or a
number in our case it makes sense to use
of a username because that's all we
really have and just like we specified
the users end point up here down here we
need to specify the authenticate
endpoints so must even now local host
port 3001 slash or prevent saccades
in that same snippet I call chat magic
Connect and assign the result to a
variable or a constant sorry called
current user now this represents the
current user we should be able to come
here and print the current user to the
console and we can poke around to see
what is available on that current user
spoiler most interactions with chat
happen on this current user for example
we'll call current user DOS and message
and so on but actually I can tell you
right away that this is not going to
work if we run this application now it
would blow up and the simple reason is
that the chat cake line SDK this module
we import up here doesn't work with
nodejs out-of-the-box like I mentioned
at the beginning of this tutorial I work
on the checker team and when we started
building this client's SDK it was mainly
built against the web browser which
means internally it uses some functions
which exist in the web browser but not
in nodejs so to use the chalk a client
in nodejs we basically need to the lack
of a better word trick checker into
thinking it's working in the browser to
do this we can use an NPM module called
Jazz Dom which will need to import
and then we'll create a function called
make check node compatible this is a
snippet I defined for the sake of this
screencast because otherwise I wouldn't
have remembered the details what it
really boils down to is creating this
global door/window property the check in
needs internally will need to make sure
to call this function and then once
that's all set up we should I think be
able to connect to check here and view
our current user so let's run the server
so we have something to connect to once
that's running we'll run the client in
connect is bucer and see what happens
as you can see once we connect we get a
minutes impose hard to read obviously
there's a lot of tags and a pretty big
fun and you can get an idea of the kind
of functions and properties available on
this current user we won't spend too
much time looking at it actually because
it's quite hard to discern the useful
stuff from the sort of prototype Alpern
stuff but you can see for example we
have like the user's name here so we can
access the current user's name by
writing current user don't name and so
on you know we'll see this all in action
soon enough let's allow the user to
choose a room to join and the way we'll
do this firstly is by creating a
variable called joinable rooms and
they're going to set this equal to the
result of current user they'll get
joinable rooms then we'll create a
variable Beneatha called available rooms
I'll explain the distinction in a second
but in a nutshell we take the current
user dot room's property and the
joinable rooms constant we just defined
and we merge these two arrays now what's
happening here because it seems like
we're conflating two ideas I say that
we're going to allow user to join a room
but then we have two concepts joinable
and available rooms well in chat care
basically you have this concept of a
join able room it's a room that racket
user is eligible to join they have
permission to do so and the room exists
but they haven't yet joined once they
join that room is said that the user
belongs to our room and so you can
access an array of all the youth rooms
where a user belongs to virus current
user dog rooms property now there's a
difference between how you represent
this in our code and how he presents it
to the user the way we'll present it to
the user is the old rooms are joinable
even if the user has already joined the
room
this might sound complicated so it might
be a bit easier to see in action once we
have this available rooms property what
we'll do is we'll write them all to the
console or write available rooms dot for
each we'll take the room and we'll take
the index and we'll print that to the
console so we'll print out the index and
then we'll print out the room name you
know if we run this right now we
wouldn't actually see anything because
we haven't created any childcare rooms
we have to do that ourselves and there
are two ways of approaching this we can
either create rooms programmatically
using one of the SDKs and this is the
recommended way and in any real
application this is likely the only way
for example imagine you're building an
application similar to slack or similar
to messenger when someone creates a new
group you know you're going to need to
write some code for creates that group
dynamically invites members dynamically
all that kind of stuff because we kind
of know our parameters here because this
is a tutorial we're going to use the
second approach which is to use the chat
kit dashboard and more specifically the
chuckit dashboard and spag dear
inspector inspector here we can create
an admin user and then creates a room
I'll call mine general in fact I'll
creates UI for every one called general
and I'll create one called free code
camp which can be a chatroom that people
can come to to talk about free code camp
now we have those two rooms I would
expect that if I run the server and if I
run the client and connected as Booker
we should be shown a list of available
rooms and he probably are we are
actually but this is a bed this is a bit
broken unless debug this together first
of all the outputs of bed master because
we're still printing out the current
user let's fix that the second problem I
think is that we see the room index zero
and it says it's undefined and I'm
trying to think why that is oh I know
why it's because in addition to be
structuring the current use of the rooms
property will also need to be structured
the joinable rooms constant and if
you're not familiar with the structure I
should have mentioned this earlier I'm
gonna make sure to link a tutorial in
the description it might be a confusing
concept as like even myself got
Confucius then apparently but in a
nutshell enables you to join arrays
let's try this again hopefully now we
see a cleaner Emperor and the expected
input no less
as you can see we have the option to
join the general room or the free code
camp room next let's prompt the user to
choose one of those rooms and so let me
just bring this up a little bit and then
we'll create another schemer this time
we'll call this room schema the
description is going to be select a room
and we'll call this some inputs chosen
room we'll come down here inside concen
room equals awaits Ghats this is the
same gap function we defined earlier
remember this guy and it will pass in
the room schema once we have that we can
actually pull down the room using the
index which is essentially what we
user-supplied
right they enter the number 0 or 1 in
this case that will correspond to an
index in the array in that available
rooms array that I'm highlighting right
now and and so we can write available
rooms chosen room and then it's time to
subscribe to that room
sniff it which can help me do this
called subscribe or sub because I'm lazy
and I do this a lot the room idea is
going to be equal to room tidy in fact
let me take a step back here this
subscribe to room function takes a few
different options firstly it takes the
room ID namely the room to subscribe to
in this case it's going to be whichever
room the user selects then we have the
opportunity to specify some hooks the
idea of hooks might be familiar to you
but it might be more easy to understand
if you think about them as events and
event handlers for instance whenever a
new message is sent in our chat room
this on new message function is going to
be called this function is going to be
called when the current user sends a
message that happens in real time which
is fairly unimpressive right calling a
function on the same client that caused
that function to be executed but the
place where check it really comes in
here is that if we distribute this chats
application to a bunch of our friends or
a bunch of users as they send messages
in the same room this only message
function is going to get executed in
real time with their messages here we
can write the messages to the console
the ones who include the message dots
sender ID which is essentially their
user name in our case as well as the
message text itself and actually we're
only going to print this message FD
message dot sender ID is not equal to
our user name because if we're the
person who sent the message we don't
need that to be relayed to ourselves
because we're going to see it in the
terminal in / anyway there's no need
obviously to notes by the current user
but they sends a message of course they
know this is tricky to demonstrate
because whilst we can subscribe to
messages we can actually send masters
yet let's do that now we'll want to
capture the user input repeatedly right
so we'll want the user to be able to
send one message whenever and so on now
we could probably adapt the prompt and
p.m. module to do this but there's
actually a much more suitable module
called read line which I'll install now
so I'll write npm install' - - save read
line actually I did notice this when I
started recording this screencast but it
seems like in notes hand there's another
module called line by line that might be
a bit more suitable I'll leave that up
to you to look into I'm going to use red
line because it's why I know and what I
know about red line is that you need to
import that well I know more than that
was pretty pretty obvious I would say
but yeah well import red line and then
down here beneath our call to subscribe
to a room we're going to want to create
a constant called inputs that we're
going to set equal to red line that
creates interface and we call create
interface we specify an inputs option
which is going to be equal to processed
or STD n st BN is like a fancy word for
the terminal in polly we often refer to
the Alpers STD out as well which you
might find interesting if you didn't
know already then we can call input on
line and then we'll create an async
callback function which gives us that
line all that tags basically and from
here we can write current user does send
message when we call send message we
need to specify the room that we're
sending that message to all messages
have to be sent to a room so that'll be
equal to room de ID and then message
itself which is going to be equal to the
text property
that looks good let's test this out I
think this should pretty much work how
we expect and has ever I'll run the
server then connect with the client in
fact you know do you know what let's
create a new window here first we'll run
the server down we'll run one clients
and then we'll run another clients so
when this first time we'll say what my
name is Booker and this client I'll say
my name is Hugo Hugo co-wrote the
tutorial with me awesome dude
and we'll both join the free code camp
channel so I'll join the free code camp
channel and then I'll join the free code
camp channel for Hugo and then to be
honest as I'm doing this now it would be
nice to have some indication as to when
we've connected right now it just feels
a bit laggy if I write hello we should
see in the other console on the right
there the book has said hello and we
don't I'm just really sad
let's figure out why
so again our hair which
as expected room ID to be a type number
there was a type undefined and that's
quite strange because I really don't see
why room would be undefined here which
line did that happen on line 85 so yeah
right here
ah so what I'm doing is I'm looking up
here where I access room tidy and I'm
sure this worked and so room tidy can't
be undefined that wouldn't make sense to
me anyway but I'm looking at the wrong
side of the assignment what I'm actually
doing here is assigning a property
called room ID and down here I'm
assigning it to a property called room
and what I'm answer is room I be let's
save that and try again so let's just
kill these clients real quick and rerun
them my name is Booker then as a new
user let's call that new user Bob will
both join the free code camp room and
here I can write hello and as I write
hello we should see the in the ever
window Booker said hello Bob convinced
say hi back and we can see in the other
window that Bob said hi you know
obviously these two clients are running
side by side on the same machine in the
same terminal but we could equally send
this file to a friend you know Hugo
lives in Australia I live in London we
can both communicate on completely
different machines across the ocean such
as the internet which isn't that
impressive but I just want to reinforce
eyes but even though this is happening
locally it would also work remotely but
yeah that pretty much wraps up the
tutorial in summary we built a chat
application where we can create users
create rooms join rooms and send and
receive messages there's so much more we
could do to this application if we had
time from both a chats perspective and a
terminal perspective right so we're
barely touching the surface of what I
can do
we're barely touching the surface of
what you can build in the terminal one
cool idea hugo and i had was if we could
list a list of online users as well as
users who have joined the chat
previously but aren't online that would
be such a cool terminal interface and it
would use a feature of chat care called
check a presence basically we can even
show typing indicators and read receive
so many cool things but like i say we
need to give it a rest for now if you'd
be interested to learn more if you want
to see a continuation of this
application a part two if you will
please let us know in the
comments or in the comments over on
medium you might also want to check out
the medium post because in addition to
what you've just seen me build right
here we also outline how to add a
loading spinner to your application
which is a really nifty way to make your
application feel faster and as well just
as well just for a bit of fun right but
yeah thank you so much for watching
please do make sure to subscribe both to
the free code camp YouTube channel as
well as myself over on the code cast
YouTube channel you can also follow
myself on twitter i'm at bukit Kurds
monkey